has the Prime Minister made a decision
yet on Dominic Rob's future no he hasn't
um he's taking his time to consider the
report he did only receive the report
yesterday and of course it's a report
produced after a five-month inquiry so
um I'm assuming it'll be no doubt an
extensive report and the prime minister
is a man who want to take the time to
read the report in full go through the
detail before he reaches a conclusion
this is an important matter it's
important both for the complainants that
have made complaints about Dominic Robb
and also for Mr Rob and the Prime
Minister will want to make the right
decision and be fair to both groups of
people
when will he make his decision will it
be today well look he wants to he'll
want to reach a conclusion as quickly as
he can this is an important matter but
he'll also want to take the time to get
it right and as I said he only received
the report yesterday and it's a report
produced after a five-month inquiry by a
senior KC so you know there's a balance
to strike here about taking the time to
get it right and of course as you've
reflected in your report there are lots
of other things that the Prime Minister
has to focus on as well as this so I
think it's important he takes the time
but he will want to reach a a swift
conclusion after taking the time to to
go through conclusion can you give us a
rough time frame when we should get a
decision by will we get one by the end
of today and that's all you can use any
idea I'm not going to speculate about it
look I haven't read the report myself
um the prime minister is doing that and
he will obviously want to reach a swift
conclusion but I said he did only
receive the report yesterday and it is
as a result of a five-month inquiry so I
think it's people are being reasonable
about it I think people would want him
to take the time read the report in full
himself before he reaches a conclusion
and that would be fair actually to those
that have made the complaints as well as
to the Deputy Prime Minister if is it
fair to say that if this report was
conclusive there'd be a decision by the
Prime Minister by now does this imply
that the report is finally balanced well
look I I don't think people should read
anything into it that's I've read those
reports but I think that's speculation
you know I haven't read the report
myself I I prefer to I think due process
is important in these matters you know
the Prime Minister set up an inquiry
with a very credible serious KC to do
the inquiry and I think actually if
you're going to do justice to the
process
um you should he should take the time to
read the report and actually we
shouldn't speculate now I certainly as a
member of the government shouldn't
speculate about it I think we should
give the premise of the time to make
decision he'll want to reach us with
conclusion but as I said he only got the
report yesterday okay and it's for the
prime minister to make the decision you
talk about due process but is he minded
to show the report to his ethics advisor
Laurie Magnus well look fundamentally
this is a decision for the Prime
Minister the the Casey that he appointed
Adam told his job was to established the
facts was to talk to the complainants to
talk to Dominic Raab to talk to other
people who could throw light on the
circumstances involved and that means
the Prime Minister will have all of the
facts in front of them but fundamentally
it's a decision for him about who serves
in the government so it's a decision for
him and and he'll take that decision you
know in the careful meticulous way that
he reaches all his decisions okay and
Dominic Robb promised to resign if the
report conclusively showed that he'd
bullied staff he hasn't resigned he
continues to maintain as we understand
it that he behaved professionally that
would imply the report is inconclusive
doesn't it well well look I haven't
Dominic Rob as far as I'm aware hasn't
said anything himself
um since
the report was received he has I think
all through the process he's been very
clear that he would fully comply with
the the process which he has and I know
when I've seen him being interviewed
he's been very careful to respect
process and not try and prejudge it and
not speculate about it so I think that
that's the best solution so I think it's
better if people just wait not speculate
wait for the outcome of the process
um and then and then until people have
actually seen the contents of the report
I know it is difficult when when none of
us have seen this but I just wonder what
your reaction is to the fact that
Dominic Robb as we understand it he's
seen the report but he hasn't quit well
I think you're trying to draw me into
speculating about what the contents of
the report are which I completely
understand and I completely understand
people you know wanting to know what the
promises decision is going to be but as
I said it's I think after a five-month
inquiry I think also you've got to
remember there were serious complaints
that were made and I think it's also
worth remembering this you know the
media reporting obviously focuses on the
future of the Deputy Prime Minister but
you know there were people involved here
who have made serious complaints and I
think you've got to be fair to them as
well and I think it's by treating this
seriously the prime minister taking the
time to read the report in detail before
reaching conclusion it's putting proper
weight on the complaints that have been
made as well as on the future of the
Deputy Prime Minister has the Prime
Minister spoken to Dominic role
I don't know I haven't spoken to the
Prime Minister uh I don't know whether
he has spoken to the Deputy Prime
Minister but actually the right thing
for the prime minister is to read the
report to understand the facts the the
whole point about why Adam totally was
asked to do the inquiry was to establish
the facts to listen to the complainants
to talk to Dominic Robb and to other
people involved in the process and it's
it's the report that will then set out
for the Prime Minister the facts and
it's on the basis of those facts that he
can then reach a conclusion asking Stan
does the Prime Minister still have full
confidence in the Deputy Prime Minister
well look you're trying to draw me into
a conclusion the prime ministers the
prime ministers had the report and he's
in the process of going through what
will no doubt be an extensive report
after a five-month inquiry
um he will then reach a conclusion
um I understand he hasn't yet made a
decision and he'll set that out in in
the usual way and then and we'll know
what the position is and I think you're
trying to draw me into speculate he's in
the Pro process of reaching that
conclusion and he'll set that as soon as
he's able okay I think a lot of people
just have a lot of questions that's all
but let me but let me move on to another
subject because today marks the start of
four days of protests by Extinction
rebellion and other groups in London
um How concerned are you about
disruption well I'd say a couple of
things first of all the big event this
weekend with the marathon I I would be
appalled if that was disrupted you know
there are thousands of people that take
part in that race who are who will have
trained all year who are raising money
for charity and I think it would be
appalling if it was disrupted so that's
the the first point the second point is
the protesters I think have got
completely the wrong target here they're
making very serious points about climate
change Britain is one of the countries
in this government is one of the
governments that's leading the the fight
against climate change we only just a
few weeks ago main Department published
our zero emission vehicle mandate about
how we're going to decarbonize Road
Transport we published our details about
how we're going to make Aviation more
sustainable by using sustainable
aviation fuel now this government is
actually leading the fight globally
against climate change actually just up
all protesters would be much better
spend going and protesting in countries
where they don't take this seriously
rather than actually disrupting the
lives of millions of ordinary people who
are trying to go on about their lives in
a country which is led by a government
which is taking this very seriously do
concerns as transport secretary for the
transport system are you confident it'll
be running smoothly as usual this
weekend well look we obviously look at
potential threats to our Public Services
you know we obviously look at the
intelligence that's out there and we
obviously take all the proper steps to
make sure that we can keep the transport
system running that we can always see
prevent disruption and I know if anybody
does break the law then you know we will
use all of the forces at our disposal to
make sure that we can protect ordinary
people going about their lives and
people that are you know for example
running in the marathon or raising money
for charity and I just hope people use
their Democratic processes and they
don't try and break the law or disrupt
ordinary people going about their lives